the movie opens up in the year 2012 in a
small neighborhood in london people are
going about their daily lives and
everything seems to be normal just then
an elderly woman maeve senses something
in the area and stops she seems worried
as if she has felt an external force one
of the neighbors trish asks maeve if she
is all right but the old lady mentions
that it's happening again out of nowhere
she rushes to the nearby kids and orders
them to get inside their homes the
neighbors are perplexed as it is a
perfectly normal day with no signs of
any danger but maeve keeps saying it's
happening again meanwhile we are shown
the poster of a missing girl signaling
that she was abducted not so long ago as
maeve is trying to convince her
neighbors trish's daughter chloe watches
everything unfold from her room across
the street she is singing her favorite
song which talks about the bird
kookaburra she then sits on her desk and
starts sketching a picture of one of the
neighbor boys who is playing outside
surprisingly as soon as she finishes the
sketch the boy vanishes into thin air as
if he has been teleported maeve and the
boy's father realized that another
abduction has taken place but they can
do nothing about it aside from maybe
taking away that girl's crayons
following this we are introduced to the
main protagonist the doctor and his
accomplice rose the two are time
travelers who have been tasked with
fixing any anomalies in the timeline
they have come into this world through
their teleportation portal however this
time they are simply there to witness
the opening ceremony of the 2012 london
olympics as the two are walking through
the same neighborhood they come across
the posters of the missing children the
doctor being a curious individual
doesn't believe that someone in a quiet
neighborhood like this one is capable of
abducting children hence he goes around
the neighborhood and starts inspecting
when he reaches near the house where the
last boy disappeared he suddenly senses
a wave of energy thus concluding that
the abductions are related to something
supernatural meanwhile rose talks to a
maintenance worker named kell who has
been fixing the potholes in the
neighborhood it turns out that the
olympic torch is going to pass through
this street on the way to wembley
stadium on the other hand the doctor
gets into trouble for snooping around
someone's house like a thief rose and
cal rushed to help him out while maeve
and trish arrive to defuse the commotion
once everyone is gathered the doctor
takes out his police badge and mentions
that he is a detective sent by the
government to solve the missing
children's case when he asks if anyone
has any information about the abductions
maeve steps forward and reveals that an
external force is taking the children
away and she can feel them the group
ignores how suss that was and continues
discussing as they do chloe can again be
seen watching everything from her room
she notices a cat and gets back to her
desk to start sketching while she is at
it her mother trish comes into her room
and tries to talk to her however the
little girl acts unruly and orders trish
to go away as she is busy go get my
pop-tarts and juice we also see several
sketches of her wall indicating that she
has been doing this for quite some time
outside the doctor and rose come across
the cat and start playing with it
however as soon as chloe finishes her
sketch the cat enters a small box as if
it is being called surprisingly it
vanishes inside the box leaving the
doctor and rose stunned that was some
schrodinger [ __ ] in the next scene as
rose is investigating the neighborhood
alone she hears a strange noise coming
out of one of the houses although
hesitant she opens the door and a large
supernatural looking ball jumps at her
fortunately the doctor arrives in the
nick of time and neutralizes the ball
hence saving her life later the two take
the strange ball to their lab to find
out its composition after a bit of
research the doctor finds out that the
ball is actually made of graphite the
same substance that is found in an hb
pencil he also gets to know that the
ball is charged with ionic energy and
that is why it came to life with all the
information the doctor concludes that
the ball is just a pencil scribble which
was thrown away after the sketch became
useless hearing this rose chips in with
her theory that whoever is making the
sketches has the power to either create
or erase things from earth she also
suspects chloe as the little girl is the
only one who doesn't come out of her
house and looks weird all the time harsh
the following day the two arrive outside
chloe's house to meet her but they are
stopped by trish who mentions that her
daughter is busy she also looks scared
as if she is hiding something the doctor
senses this and promises to help her
daughter and this time trish agrees
after letting them in trish reveals that
chloe has been acting strange for the
last couple of months she never leaves
her room and scribbles random sketches
all day long trish also mentions that
her husband died a year ago and they're
happy about it since he was a very bad
person as the three continue discussing
rose asks for a bathroom break and heads
upstairs there she notices chloe getting
outside her room and quickly hides after
the little girl is out of sight rose
heads into her room and notices the
weird sketches on the wall she also
hears an unusual noise coming from the
closet when she opens it she is taken
aback to witness a talking entity the
entity is a scary looking sketch made on
the wall and it keeps on saying i'm
coming
okay meanwhile the doctor meets with
chloe and tries to interrogate her but
the girl again says that she's busy
suddenly he hears rose's scream and
rushes upstairs
on reaching he sees the entity trying to
come out of the closet and immediately
closes it trish also arrives and gets
angry that the two have barged into her
daughter's room without permission just
then chloe reveals that the entity
inside the closet is her father and that
she sketched it after she saw him in her
dream worried trish asks her what's
going on but as usual chloe does not
respond after this the two time
travelers brief trish on everything that
has been happening with her daughter
they mention how chloe has been using
her sketches to make kids and animals
disappear from her neighborhood as
expected trish is dumbfounded to hear
all this but deep down inside even she
knows that something is terribly wrong
with her daughter later the three head
to the kitchen and discuss the matter at
hand trish is confused as to why chloe
drew her dead father to which the doctor
replies that he has been haunting the
little girl in her dreams then to find
more answers they again head back to the
little girl's room however this time the
doctor uses one of his spells to render
chloe unconscious so that he can talk to
the entity that is possessing her lo and
behold the entity starts speaking and
continuously mentions that it doesn't
want to be alone it then identifies
itself as an isolus a supernatural being
that travels through space with its
large family two months ago this
particular isolus became separated from
its family when a large solar flare
damaged its pod and sent it flying to
earth rose and trish can't understand
why the isilos took over chloe's body
but the doctor clarifies that these
creatures live off their family's energy
and that if they are separated for too
long they will die the isolis befriended
chloe because she had a troubled
childhood and is lonely just like it is
the isolus has also caused chloe to draw
a life-sized exaggerated figure of her
late abusive father he further mentions
that the isilos will continue kidnapping
children and other animals until it can
match the numbers of their large family
rose asks about the number and the
doctor replies 4 billion this means that
the isilis will keep using chloe to
kidnap children until it has 4 billion
family members chloe should just draw a
bunch of rats and murder hornets that
would be a win-win-win just then chloe's
father's entity inside the closet starts
banging on the door at the same time
chloe starts having a panic attack as if
her father is attacking her mentally
with time running out the doctor tells
trish to think of something that can
calm her daughter down not knowing what
to do trish starts singing the
kookaburra song unfortunately it works
the entity goes silent and chloe comes
back to life after a while the doctor
and rose head out to look for the pod
that brought the isolus to earth the
plan is to repair the pod so that the
isolis can return to its original family
surprisingly chloe is following them
everywhere they go later the two head
back to their lab and start creating a
device they can track the heat movements
of the pod and reveal its location the
task is not easy but using his
incredibly complex brain the doctor
prepares the device and finds out that
the pod is hiding somewhere in the same
neighborhood however just as they enter
the area through their teleportation
portal the doctor and the portal
disappear into thin air it turns out
that chloe has sketched the doctor as he
was becoming a major obstacle in her
plans now with her master gone rose has
to solve the case alone what if chloe
draws rose too in the next scene rose
hurries to the streets and starts
looking for the pod a few hours pass by
but she doesn't find a single clue
suddenly it strikes her mind that the
pod feeds off heat energy meaning that
it must be repairing itself in the
hottest part of the neighborhood she
then approaches kell the maintenance
worker and asks him the location of the
largest pothole he fixed recently kel
thinks for a while and points at a
nearby place where he deposited a lot of
hot tar wasting no time rose grabs an
axe and starts digging her plan comes to
fruition as just after a few minutes she
finds the pod elsewhere chloe watches
the television and sees thousands of
people in wembley stadium waiting to
witness the opening ceremony of the 2012
olympics unsurprisingly this strikes an
idea in her mind and she starts
sketching the entire stadium shortly
after rose arrives at the house with the
pod but it's too late around 80 000
people in the stadium have disappeared
into thin air and the news is being
broadcast live on television sadly this
is still not enough for the isolas and
it orders chloe to sketch the entire
earth so that it can abduct everyone and
make a large family rose tries to stop
chloe but the entity inside the closet
threatens to come out if she gets near
the child with all hope now seemingly
lost a sketch inside the room suddenly
moves it is the doctor's sketch and even
while being abducted he has managed to
communicate with rose in the sketch she
is pointing at the olympic torch at the
same time the television also starts
showing the olympic torch rally which is
nearing the neighborhood the reporter
says that the torch is a beacon of hope
integrity and love as soon as rose hears
this she realizes that the doctor is
signaling her to throw the pod inside
the olympic torch as love is the only
thing that can repair it
she immediately heads outside and joins
the large crowd that is waiting for the
olympic rally to arrive once she sees
the torch she throws the pod into the
air and it lands exactly at the right
spot with this the isolus inside chloe's
body realizes that the pot is about to
be fixed and decides to return home
after it leaves her body chloe returns
back to normalcy and hugs her mother the
other abducted children also start
reappearing and even the entire wembley
stadium is filled with the previously
abducted spectators rose celebrates her
victory with kel but when the doctor
does not reappear she becomes worried
just then she hears a monstrous scream
from chloe's house and rushes to it it
turns out that the isilos had left a
small amount of energy behind and using
it the entity from the closet has come
out it has trapped the mother-daughter
duo inside and is coming to finish them
off rose realizing that the entity is
merely a lump of energy tells chloe to
stay strong and sing her favorite song
although scared the little girl starts
singing the kookaburra song and her
mother joins in too the plan works
because the demon can't stand the sound
of their singing and it is pushed back
inside its world forever in the final
scene the television shows that the man
carrying the olympic torch is exhausted
and injured just as he is about to reach
the wembley stadium he collapses to the
ground surprisingly the doctor pops up
out of nowhere carries the torch and
heads to its designated destination as
the crowd and the entire world cheers on
he climbs up the stairs of the stadium
and lights the olympic flame
did the first torchbearer just die or
the movie ends as the pod finally
generates enough energy to travel back
to its own galaxy subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching